[Musique]
quand vous serez au bout du monde ne
serait pas encore arrivé aux kerguelen
perdu au fond de l'océan indien a touché
la ligne des 50e hurlants cet archipel
si méconnu n'a jamais fait fortune la
multitude d'îlots et par lé fur profond
et les sommets enneigés de la grande
terre ne sont en fait un parent dit que
pour les espèces animales qui s'y
prélassent dans toute liberté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à kerguelen les hommes ne brille guère
par leur présence mais tout de même il
occupe en permanence la base de port aux
français depuis 1949
là une petite centaine de scientifiques
et de militaires observent et
entretiennent l'une des dernières terres
vierges de la planète faire la carte des
kerguelen fut toute une histoire
1772 de chevalier de kerguelen découvre
ces îles sans y poser le pied
les premières cartes ne sont que des
très approximatif qui se précisent
cependant lors d'un second voyage
entrepris l'année suivante par le même
car guéret arrivent ensuite les
navigateurs anglais dont le grand coup
puis james ross les îles kerguelen
deviennent les îles de la désolation
seuls les fauqué et les baleiniers
américain exploiteront les kerguelen au
19e siècle et ce sont eux qui dessine la
première carte complète de l'archipel
mais au début de notre siècle les
kerguelen donne rendez-vous à deux fils
de famille bretons raymond et henri
rallier du bâti au terme de deux longs
voyages la première carte sérieuse de
cet archipel cran comme la corse est
imprimé en 1922
entre 1961 et 1966 l'institut
géographique national l'hygiène réalise
la carte aux cent millième 20 cm égal 1
km grâce à la photographie aérienne les
kerguelen possède enfin un vrai visage
cartographique avec le satellite spot ce
visage se précise encore davantage
puisque aujourd'hui une couverture aux
50 1000e est actuellement en cours à
bord du marion dufresne le navire
habitent ailleurs des terres australes
et antarctiques françaises
nous sommes en route vers la dernière
carte des kerguelen
celui qui se tient rêveusement à la
passerelle du marion dufresne
c'est henri gouges ingénieurs
topographes il est chargé des premières
mesures en vue de l'établissement de la
future carte spatiale des kerguelen
partie de l'île de la réunion
il faudra sept jours de mer où marion
pour parvenir aux kerguelen parcourant
ainsi 3400 kg
l'assistant et complice d'henri
s'appelle cédric chauveau l'amoureux de
ses terres australes où il retourne pour
la quatrième fois
cédric emmène avec lui une véritable
merveille une caméra par voka 35 mm vous
traquer les fantômes des ralliés du bâti
1908 à bord d'un petit à envier
rebaptisé le jb charcot en hommage à
leurs maîtres les frères rallier du bâti
en compagnie de quatre hommes d'équipage
appareils pour les kerguelen
raymond âgé de 27 ans est le chef de
cette expédition
mais c'est son frère henry qui commande
le petit nabil 1913
cette fois raymond repart sans son frère
mais toujours vers les kerguelen son
nouveau bateau la curieuse est
parfaitement équipé efficacement secondé
par jean laurent chais et georges saint
lannes grammont sa mission carte
graphique sera un succès la grande
guerre viendra interrompre ce voyage
studieux
l'homme qui écrit et qui dessine sur la
plage avant c'est gildas flahault un
grand ami d'henri de cédric il les
accompagne histoire de ramener dans ses
carnets quelques morceaux devant et de
lumière en mer ce qui est bien c'est
qu'il ne se passe rien hormis quelques
belles rencontres comme celle de bernard
froelich ingénieur en chef de l'hygiène
aujourd'hui en route vers ses souvenirs
qu'on avait quand on faisait les prises
de vue en hélico
la chambre était posée comme ceux ci sur
laquelle on positionner les magasins de
200 vue et à l'intérieur on avait qui
passait à travers la trappe
l'état va le mettre il permettait de
régler à la fois les actes de prise de
vue le point de départ et d'arrivée donc
garder le cap en fonction de la dérive
de régler la cadence de 1961 66 à 3500
mètres d'altitude
deux hélicoptères de l'armée la bourre
les kerguelen en tous sens les résultats
de cette moisson seront 5000 photos
aériennes couvrant chacune une surface
de 4 km sur quatre
pourtant il n'était pas toujours facile
de faire voler droit évite un
hélicoptère surtout aux kerguelen
normalement c'est l'avion qui est
utilisé pour la photographie aérienne
mais encore faut-il qu'il y est un
terrain d'aviation ce qui n'est pas le
cas aux kerguelen avec toute
l'opiniâtreté et les ressources qui le
caractérise le colonel gentil dès
l'année 1957 introduit un hélicoptère
jean sur les terres australes par la
suite il n'a aucun mal à convaincre
l'hygiène que l'hélicoptère est le moyen
idéal pour les travaux de la carte aux
cent millième
[Musique]
aujourd'hui d'hélicoptères s'appelle
spot et il vole à 830 km d'altitude
c'est une merveille de précision et de
technologie à l'aide de ces deux miroirs
orientables depuis la terre au centième
de degré près il prend des images ou
plus précisément des scènes qui couvre
en une seule fois des superficies de 60
km sur 60
[Musique]
la scène spot de la partie orientale des
kerguelen vient d'être prise mais ce
n'est pas encore une carte
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut se
rendre sur le terrain et repérer des
points qui seront visibles depuis le
satellite dont la précision est de 10 m
au sol comme par exemple le boudent
cette pointe il faudra enregistrer
précisément la latitude et la longitude
de ces points et alors seulement il sera
possible de superposer la scène spot à
une carte pour chaque scène il faut
entre six et dix points d'appui ou le
calage au sol c'est la mission d'henry
et de cédric son assistant
[Musique]
après kerguelen à son second voyage
après coup quand l'un d'eux grazi 776 et
après le jb charcot défaire rallier
sépare les îles nuageuse tout au nord de
l'archipel que le marion dufresne aborde
les kerguelen
kerguelen ne pose à jamais le pied sur
la terre qui porte son nom
c'est sans doute ce qui lui permis
d'écrire tout ce que les yeux ont pu
reconnaître est entrecoupé de bois et de
verdure ce qui semble annoncer un pays
peuplé et cultivé avec réflexion
ces déclarations hallucine élus voteront
la prison et rappelleront à toutes fins
utiles que les kerguelen ont à offrir
que leur splendide désolation autant d
exploration lorsqu il ne s'agissait pas
d'une seule et même personne
le dessinateur accompagner toujours le
géographe la préoccupation première
était de lever le dessin des côtes
ce dessin ira sans cesse s'améliorant
mais les cartes marines ignorons
toujours superbement ce qui se joue à
l'intérieur des terres
seule compte pour les marins la manière
dont ils pourront aborder et quitter ses
terres sans risque de perdre leurs
navires
[Musique]
il y a trente ans pratiquement jour pour
jour
bernard débarqué ici à port christmas
avec hervé durand de corbiac et hervé
guichard
il faisait partie de la troisième
campagne cartes graphiques menée par
l'hygiène saluer cordialement par une
bande manchots royaux
cette mission avait pour objectif de
combler les derniers blanc de la carte
dans le nord de l'archipel sur la
péninsule laurent chef il allait rester
plus d'un mois à port christmas
henri cédric et gildas ne resteront que
deux jours à port christmas pour le
débarquement de leur matériel et de
leurs vivres l'hélicoptère est encore
l'outil idéal
quant à bernard il restera à bord du
marion dufresne qui ralliera dans la
nuit port aux français la capitale des
kerguelen de port aux français
il sautera à bord de la curieuse pour
venir chercher nos aventuriers de porter
ce mas
[Musique]
kerguelen restent encore le pays des
premiers matins du monde depuis que les
chasseurs de phoques et baleines ont
disparu les hommes passant devant de
véritables martien pour les animaux
gildas ne pouvais pas rêver d'un
meilleur endroit pour y exercer ses
talents de peintre naturaliste
mais l'état de nature ne rime pas
forcément avec le paradis et cet univers
animal est impitoyable c'est otaries
blessés lors de combats avec ses
congénères se fait littéralement
déguster sur place par ce petit ionis si
le tard il ne parvient pas à regagner la
mer alors ce sera la curie premier point
ici l'espèce de petites barres rocheuses
sur la carte de son île c'est en fait ce
rocher on va se mettre complètement à
droite il ya un petit nez sur crurent là
on repérera très bien ce point sur le
cliché spot l'un petit échancrure repéré
par henry sur la carte sera parfaitement
visible sur l'image satellite en
connaissant sa position exacte grâce au
gps l'échancrure deviendra l'un des
points d'appui de la scène spot qui
couvrira le nord des kerguelen pour
couvrir l'ensemble de l'archipel
il faudra 5 à 6m spot il faudra aussi un
temps parfaitement dégagées
car les images satellites n'aime guère
les nuages
un jour de noël 10 776 les deux navires
de cook
la résolution et la discovery molière
dans cette baie qu'ils baptisèrent tout
naturellement port christmas la fameuse
arche des kerguelen étaient encore en
place
il faisait un temps merveilleux tout
comme aujourd'hui où l'été austral qui
s'étend de décembre à mars brille de
tous ses feux des feux pas si chaud tout
de même car la température ne dépasse
guère les 10 degrés mais pour les
otaries et les cormorans c'est la
canicule
le gps d'henry est un récepteur
calculateur reliés à une antenne gps
signifie global positionning system
autrement dit en français système de
positionnement global
ce système de localisation a été mis au
point par la nasa et le récepteur
d'henri peut recevoir les signaux de 24
satellites qui gravitent autour de la
terre
les satellites émettent des messages qui
comporte une position dans le ciel est
une heure en temps absolu si le gps
reçoit les signaux d'au moins quatre
satellites
il peut alors calculer la position
exacte en latitude longitude et altitude
du point où ils se trouvent
c'est un système précis à 10 cm
ce qui est largement suffisant puisque
la précision visuelle de spots et 2,10 m
ok
[Musique]
dans l'après midi henry et cédric grimpe
pour leur second point gps qui se situe
juste au déversoir du lac rochegude au
dessus de port christmas ils sont
rejoints par gildas qui a bien travaillé
de son côté
[Musique]
demain la curieuse le navire de
l'institut français de recherche et de
technologie polaire l'iaf rpp arrivera
aux aurores ce portrait ce mas oui
bonjour bonjour comment ça va bien
dormez on a eu quand même beaucoup de
vent là mais enfin les temps ne se sont
pas envolées tout va bien est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner une heure
approximative de votre arrivée
l'homme est retourné dans le travers de
leur temps dans ma maison de retraite
après une nuit de mer agitée bernard
revient de port aux français les
souvenirs aussi pure que l'ère des
kerguelen
avec havane était là haut il reste que
les plateformes le vin a tout emporté
combien de temps vous êtes restés dans
les cabanes on est resté un mois et demi
helvétique ont bien avant on était en
étaient huit dont deux géographes et six
pilotes et mécanos des lycées pour deux
hélicos une journée de travail où on
pouvait travailler ça représentait 8
heures du matin 8 heures du soir
par contre il ya des jours entiers où on
est resté dans les cabanes dans le
mauvais temps attendre que ça se passe
quoi et de l'hélico après vous avez fait
beaucoup d'heures dans tous les
déplacements sous un hélico et toutes
les tous l'accès aux points c'est un
hélico et en plus les photos aériennes
et heureusement on a pu vers la fin
faire des photos aériennes parce que il
y avait encore des trous et on a réussi
à boucher les trous en photos aériennes
en hélico finalement vous avez
pratiquement pu faire tout ce que vous
aviez faire que m'ont élevé oui puisque
la mission à laquelle j'ai participé
c'était la dernière et on a réussi à
finir les travaux pour la carte et là on
a découvert des choses qu'on ignorait
d'eilat d'école des vallées et personne
n'avait vu et vous avez laissé quelques
traces de les signer cabanas signé oui
on a donné des noms on a proposé à la
commission de toponymie des tas de noms
par exemple il dit chara avait baptisé
le monde du théodolite il ya le col des
géographes il ya vendu des noms comme ça
et puis on s'est octroyé chacun pour nos
épouses le prénom nos épouses à la et
moi j'ai mon petit lac michel
[Musique]
elle n'a l'air de rien à la petite
curieuse mais il s'agit tout de même
d'un véritable navire océanographique
parfaitement adapté pour découvrir
toutes les curiosités du monde des
kerguelen c'est elle qui transporte en
toute sécurité les scientifiques ayant
sans cesse besoin de se déplacer d'un
point à un autre de cet archipel très
découpées aujourd'hui le point gps doit
se faire à peau mate à une vingtaine de
milles au sud de port cros masse
[Musique]
du temps de bernard la cartographie ne
pouvait se passer des sommets la
géodésie c'est à dire la science de la
forme des dimensions de la terre
s'élaborait grâce à l'observation d'un
sommet un autre à partir d'un point
fondamental et en recoupant les
observations on obtenait ainsi une
armature géodésique de lille sur la base
de cette armature on pouvait ensuite
parfaitement positionné le dessin de la
carte obtenue grâce aux prises de vue
aériennes
mais à l'heure du satellite il n'est
plus besoin de grimper sur les sommets
ce petit cap sur le boul qu'elle opère
cédric et henry sera visible à 830 km
d'altitude par spot et grâce au gps
on ne connaîtra la position à 10
centimètres près
il faudra une petite demi-heure à henry
et à cédric pour accomplir leur tâche
avec des gestes précis et rapide comme
pour une manoeuvre de reggane
j'ai dit sur la demande pressante de
cédric la curieuse fait route vers la
presqu'île de la société de géographie
ainsi baptisé par les frères rallier
parce que l'honorable société participe
pas au financement des expéditions du jb
charcot et de la première curieuse en
1913 au cours du voyage de la curieuse
il y avait une caméra à bord mais nul ne
sait ce que sont devenus les films
ont-ils seulement été développé c'est
pour remédier à cette perte que cédric à
transporter sa précieuse caméra bout du
monde
si le premier voyage de remo rallier aux
kerguelen fut celui de la découverte de
l'émerveillement le second voyage fut
celui de l'étude et de la science
la curieuse était un bateau neuf dessiné
pour l'occasion est doté d'un moteur
ayant en fait défaut lors du premier
voyage
les six hommes d'équipage de la curieuse
et son état-major firent un travail
absolument remarquable et toute la côte
ouest de l'île fut reconnu pour la
première fois la grande guerre
interrompit ce voyage elle interrompu
aussi l'avis d'henri rallier du bâti
profondément affecté raymond publia
cependant 1922 la première vraie carte
des kerguelen et accompli par la suite
une brillante carrière océanographique
réfugié dans ses souvenirs il mourut en
1978 à locmiquélic dans le morbihan
très certainement en songeant à la
sombre beauté de ces îles dont il avait
su se faire aimer
[Musique]
la curieuse à mouiller de nuit dans la
petite rade de port couvreux la carte de
1937 du service hydrographique de la
marine basée entièrement sur les travaux
et frère rallier porte mention d'une
maison d'un magasin mêmes dunks et rené
bossière
si henry et bernard partent vers une
hauteur proche afin de se livrer à l'art
de la topographie gildas quant à lui est
bien décidé à rester à pau recouvre eux
afin d'en percer les mystères
les mystères il en subsiste apport
couvreux un meurtre il fut même commis à
la fin des années 20 les frères bossière
concessionnaire exclusif des îles
kerguelen depuis 1893 tentèrent
d'acclimater des moutons qui firent
venir des îles falkland l'entreprise ne
sera jamais un succès et pas plus les
hommes que leurs moutons ne firent
souchet kerguelen
à 104 mètres au dessus du niveau de la
mer bernard a décidé d'initier henry au
charme des vieilles méthodes et plus
particulièrement celles des stations au
sol
250 de ses stations au sol et sans point
géodésique sûr nécessaires pour établir
la carte aux cent millième des
directions des pentes et un tour
d'horizon graphique expédié pour montrer
ce qu'on avait visé le col sommet un
prêt c'est tout cette méthode ancienne
la permettait de lever une carte mais à
condition de commencer par les auteurs
et ensuite on exploiter sur les photos
tous toutes ces intersections ont
calculé tous les points ça permettait de
mettre en place le dessin d'après la
photo vous pouvez travailler avec du
vent quand même la pluie tous
instruments sortait en sortait en hélico
jusqu'à 100 kilomètres heure devant je
te dis pas que c'était toujours facile
je me souviens de stations où j'ai
terminé à genoux cramponné à la planche
est le résultat de ces travaux
c'est le merveilleux dessin de la carto
son millième avec ses velouté d'ombré de
lumière
cette carte est là qu est parfait
ouvrant la porte des kerguelen
trois petits milles plus tard et la
curieuse relâche dans le bassin de la
gazelle un haut lieu de la mythologie
des ralliés ce soir dans le carré de la
nouvelle curieuse tous les fantômes sont
convoqués les frères ravier du bâti avec
leur gilet charcot sont arrivés sur les
lieux le rolland ou de là ils ont passé
sur portrait ce parce qu'ils ont mouillé
cela non plus les premiers éléphants et
sans parti uni et la belugo maintenant
pour matin et puis ils ont contourné
tout ça et ils sont venus mouiller pour
hiberner au bassin de la gazette
attendait temps d'écouter ça justement
ce soir là mon frère et moi assis dans
la cabine par l'âme de nos projets
tandis que sur le pont agnès jouaient
une musique douce sur son accordéon
enrayer mois assis devant la carte où
nous regardions avec un sentiment de
gratitude des mois d' aventure d'une
autre sorte vous attend dès maintenant
car gehlen était à nous il n'y avait pas
âme qui vive pour réclamer une
quelconque parcelle de l'île de la
désolation
mais avant qu'elle fut vraiment à nous
nous devions en explorer les moindres
recoins et combler les lacunes de la
carte
[Musique]
dix neuf huit sept six cinq quatre trois
ce matin cédric et partis de bonne heure
marcher dans les pas des frères rallier
du bâti et de leurs équipages
le premier voyage les frères rallier
s'appuie sur la carte de 1870 du dépôt
des cartes et plans de la marine une
carte elle même inspirée par celle des
baleiniers américain c'est une époque
heureuse puisque il reste encore des
blancs sur les cartes marines nos deux
jeunes fils de famille ont largement de
quoi satisfaire leur soif d'aventuré et
leur désir de se rendre utile auprès de
leurs frères marin
[Musique]
ouais
de ces deux voyages aux kerguelen
raymond rallier avait une préférence
très net pour celui du jb charcot
quand cédric il aurait donné cher pour
faire partie de l'équipage
ce voyage du jb charcot et celui de la
jeunesse et de l'intrépidité bien sûr le
but avoué est de prendre des
observations pour faire la carte
mais durant ce premier séjour de 16 mois
au caire gehlen la chasse aux éléphants
de mer leur dépeçage et la fonte douleur
grèce pour obtenir une huile précieuse
occupe une grande partie du temps de
nous deux jeunes aristocrates breton
lundi 11 janvier beau temps continue et
la fonte et la chasse tué 20 éléphants
de mer
avant tu es certainement tous les
phoques qui se trouvait dans port
elizabeth
il faudra désormais aller dans les
criques environnants bien que fils de
bonne famille des frères rallier ne sont
pas vraiment riche
les expéditions coûte encore cher il
faut bien trouver une source de revenus
de même et c'est un souci constant de
raymond il faut payer l'équipage les
pauvres et des points de mer en feront
les frais et lorsque le jb charcot keep
les kerguelen
il a deux dans ses cales 80 baril de la
meilleure huile qui puisse se trouver
cependant n'allez pas croire que les
frères rallier furent seulement des
chasseurs de phoques jamais il
n'oubliera le but scientifique de leur
voyage dimanche 28 beau temps travaillé
aujourd'hui avec l'assentiment des
hommes qui prendront leur jour de repos
un jour de mauvais temps près une
observation méridienne à l'horizon
artificiel
or elizabeth doit être reportée 2000
plus sud que sur la carte
souvent en fin de semaine raymond parent
avec l'un des membres de son équipage
pour découvrir en doris ou à pied les
coins perdus des kerguelen de ses
navigations et de ces marches naîtra un
livre merveilleux aventure aux kerguelen
à ces valeureux membres d'équipage
raymond rallier offre les kerguelen et
nous le novice aussi brave comme mauvais
cuisinier possède sa creek sur l'île
roland un fjord et une belle porte le
nom du matelot la rose celui qu'on
surnommait le moulin à biscuits dans son
appétit était grand fin joueur
d'accordéon et lecteurs d'arthur gordon
pym les mélodies du matelot agnès plane
aujourd'hui sur un petit port des
kerguelen et c'est un lac profond qui
portent la mémoire du basque bon temps
le taciturne et compétent bosco du jb
charcot quant aux frères raymond et
henry ils sont devenus des montagnes
dans la péninsule qui porte leur nom de
famille ils ont enfin l'éternité pour
évoquer leurs souvenirs d'enfance en
hommage à ces hommes raymond écrivit
ceci il est un endroit sur la terre ou
la mort même ne pourra entièrement
abolir votre mémoire
c'est là-bas aux îles de kerguelen
quittant le bassin de la gazelle et son
mouillage impeccable il faudra deux
petites heures et quelques dauphins de
commerçants pour gagner port elizabeth
le point gps de port elizabeth sera vite
expédiée de retour à bord jean-marc de
patron de la curieuse donne le programme
eh bien on va contourner la péninsule
courbe
on devrait mettre environ
huit heures avant d'arriver au
il ya jeu
nous sommes fiers on va passer la nuit
plate comme la main la péninsule courbet
défilent dans la douceur du soir quand
la nuit nous prendrons le mouillage à
lille du cimetière
certains baleiniers et fauqué américain
du siècle dernier sont restés ici pour
l'éternité
le temps n'a pas su conserver leur nom
mais le grand vent décrire galène chante
encore leur courage et la dureté de leur
vie
il repose un loose décédé à l'avant
c'est le petit mousse doigt par les
ralliés du bâti dans un bouquin
[Musique]
ce dédale d'îles et d'îlots s'appelle le
golfe du morbihan
baptisé en hommage au golfe du même nom
et sur les bords duquel les frères
rallier passèrent leur enfance c'était
du côté de vannes
bernard et gildas continueront à bord de
la curieuse avant d'être débarqué à port
jeanne d'arc
quant à cédric et henri un point gps les
attend en baie de l'observatoire
[Musique]
arrivés jusque là gardée par deux
farouches ce quoi quelques cabanes ont
ainsi été semé par l'état elie frtp afin
que les scientifiques soient proches de
leur théâtre d'opérations
si la baie de l'observatoire est ainsi
dénommée c'est parce qu en 1874 une
expédition anglaise débarquent ici pour
observer le passage de vénus sur le
soleil quelques années plus tard en 1902
une expédition allemande revient occuper
les lieux
cette mission allemande se terminera
tragiquement sans doute les hommes c'est
est il trop laissé emporter par le
schnaps que n'avait-il pas assez
surveiller leur alimentation puisque
trois des sept membres de l'équipe
moururent du béribéri les frères rallier
harry verte ici cinq ans après le drame
samedi 24 octobre
très beau temps continue la construction
des deux fourneaux depuis l'arrivée dans
la baie de l'observatoire la mise à
l'ouvragé lieu à 8h du matin repas du
midi à une heure reprise du travail
jusqu'à six heures du soir
ayant retrouvé deux chaudron laissés là
par les phoques et américains les frères
alliés font d'eux ici ce qu'il baptise
non sans humour leur usine à partir
d'octobre 1908 la baie de l'observatoire
devient le quartier général du jb
charcot c'est une période de chasse et
de faune incessantes les deux chaudron
sont alimentés par le charbon extrait
sur place au prix d'un labeur harassant
les observations scientifiques sont un
peu mise de côté
lundi 29 mauvais temps coup de vent de
nord équipage repos tous nos vêtements
sont imbibé d'huile
il est impossible d'entretenir la
moindre propreté à bord
we thought rapallo rien tout à fait on
chez rémo
en ce matin de noël cédric vient planter
une antenne d'un type nouveau
l' aventure n'exclut pas une certaine
coquetterie et il est même recommandé de
ne pas se laisser l
et puis l'eau est courante
bien qu'un peu fraîche la salle de bains
est vaste et belle avec une vue
imprenable sur la mer se raser ici ce
matin c'est déjà un cadeau de noël
sur la carte auchan millièmes il
s'agissait d' un isthme mais à mieux
regarder la prise de vue hélico dont la
définition est de 1 m il s'agissait
d'une île afin de ne pas mouiller le
précieux matériel il a bien fallu se
débrouiller pour construire un gay
[Rires]
le temps de faire 500 mètres
un grain de neige s'est abattue le temps
d'installer le matériel et il était déjà
parti ce les regards curieux des
cormorans la manoeuvre est lancé à 830
km au dessus des kerguelen spot est
programmé pour prendre deux images sous
deux angles différents
cette différence d'angle de prise de vue
permettra par la suite de restituer le
relief en associant les deux simav dans
une vision stéréoscopique spot continue
son petit bonhomme de chemin tout en
transmettant ses données sur notre terre
les images des kerguelen arrive alors à
toulouse et l'hygiène espace peut
commencer son travail de restitution
cartographique d'abord les ordinateurs
rectifie la scène spot grâce aux points
gps enregistrés sur le terrain ensuite
les deux images prises sous deux angles
différents sont associés afin d'extraire
le relief qui sera traduit en courbes de
niveau cette partie du travail s'appelle
la modélisation
enfin l'image est améliorée par un
traitement de couleurs au terme de cette
opération la spatiaux carte existe mais
elle est tout nu et il faut les habiller
c'est à dire qu'il faut porter les
latitudes et longitudes inscrire tous
les noms dessiner les cours d'eau où le
réseau routier ce qui est assez rapide
pour les kerguelen
il faudra quinze cartes de ce type pour
parvenir à couvrir les quatre cinquièmes
des kerguelen à l'échelle du 50e c'est à
dire un centimètre égale 500 m pour
l'instant il n'est pas encore prévu de
couvrir le nord de l'archipel des
kerguelen conserveront elle ainsi une
part de leur mystère
une aventure nous appellent à l'aurore
partie de port aux français qui tout
comme la baie de l'observatoire se situe
dans le golfe du morbihan
le petit challenge vient reprendre henry
et cédric l'expédition tire à sa fin et
nous deux virtuoses du gps éprouve comme
une mélancolie certains vous diront que
les kerguelen ressemble à l'ecosse à
l'islande ou je ne sais quel patagonie
en fait les kerguelen ne ressemble
cocker guelleh pour jeanne d'arc et on
retrouvera bernard et zidane
ouais c'est prévu
raymond rallier écrivait plus de mille
fois j'ai vu cette côte la beauté
particulière de kerguelen s'insinue dans
les coeurs et vous prend sous son charme
avant de hanter les mémoires des marins
qui sont aventurés
[Musique]
port jeanne d'arc était un établissement
baleinier de belle taille fondé en 1908
par les frères bossière associés à des
norvégiens
ce fut pratiquement leur seule
entreprise rentable comme pu le
constater raymond alliés revenu à pour
van darc en 1913 à bord de la curieuse
[Musique]
le quatuor se reforme henry raconte
l'abbé de l'observatoire tandis que
bernard et gildas sont loin de s'être
ennuyé durant ces deux jours bernard est
reparti marché dans le grand vent des
kerguelen et de ses souvenirs il est
très fier juste titre d'avoir été l'un
des derniers ingénieur géographe à
combler les blancs de la carte d'un
territoire français à l'époque il fumait
la pipe
hervé durand de corbiac et hervé
guichard participèrent pratiquement à
toutes les missions cartographique de 61
à 66 la carte des kerguelen leur doit
beaucoup
disparu récemment il existe forcément
deux montagnes aux kerguelen qui
porteront leurs nous et perpétueront
leurs souvenirs
et puis rien n'aurait pu se faire sans
les équipages des deux hélicoptères qui
volaient dans des conditions souvent
périlleuses faire une carte comporte
aussi des risques
de son côté gilles da n'était pas resté
inactif
le décor de port jeanne d'arc constitué
pour lui une puissante source
d'inspiration
dans une cabane ouverte à tous les vents
il s'était installé un véritable atelier
et ses carnets tempête prenait forme au
gré de sa palette et des lumières
changeantes de l'archipel bien
évidemment le livre de raymond rallier
l'accompagner dans son travail
un tel lieu ne pouvait pas non plus
laissé insensible cédric et sa caméra et
ce d'autant que les rallier à sister dès
novembre 1908 à la construction de
l'usiné mardi 3 novembre
aujourd'hui à trois heures est arrivée
en baie de l'observatoire le steamer
norvégien jeanne d'arc le capitaine ring
avait trouvé le document laissé par nous
au mas du baça de la gazelle obtenu du
café du tabac lusine préfabriqué est
monté en un temps record et deux petits
vapeur l'éclair et l'étoile partent
immédiatement en chasse les campagnes
baleinières sont plutôt bonnes mais la
distance est bien trop grande entre les
terrains de chasse et lusine pour y
ramener les baleines gonflé au gaz afin
de les faire flotter
c'est sans doute ce qui explique en
partie la ruine de lusine survenant
moins de 25 ans après sa fondation
les frères rallier ne sont désormais
plus seule à chasser aux kerguelen
mais ce n'est pas une période heureuse
pour autant henri tombe gravement malade
et doit être rapatrié au plus vite
seize mois passés dans des conditions
extrêmement dures ont ruiné sa santé
la mort dans l'âme raymond prend le
commandement du jb charcot qui
appareille le 2 juin 1909 des kerguelen
cap sur l'australie
c'est la fin d'un voyage extraordinaire
et la modestie de ce qu'ils entreprirent
n'a d'égal que leur courage quant à l'
usine de port jeanne d'arc
seuls quelques korrigans parviennent de
temps en temps à la remettre en marche
[Musique]
alors ça se termine
ben ouais tu vois on a pratiquement fini
là c'est qu'on tente avis sur câble et
toi tu veux toi kerguelen c'est
formidable
tous ces souvenirs que j'ai retrouvé
c'était formidable de faire cette carte
en partant de rien blanche dans la tarte
simplement contourné contre séville
terminé avec une carte papier imprimé en
couleurs de les faire toutes les phases
intermédiaires
ça c'était formidable je rentre je
mesure aujourd'hui la chance que j'ai
eue et les techniques nouvelles
peut-être ne permettent pas cette
aventure c'est vrai fait chacun
s'entraîne et on n'est pas dans les
satellites et oui on n'est pas dans les
activités alors que nous on était dans
l'hélico on était sur le terrain
vraiment c'était le pied
la chance et le bonheur de bernard
continue puisque l'hélicoptère embarqué
à bord du marion dufresne est venu le
reprendre à port jeanne d'arc
il fallut plus de 500 heures de vol pour
réaliser les travaux de l'a 4
l'hélicoptère servait aussi bien à
transporter les géographes de stations
au sol en station géodésique qu'à
effectuer les prises de vues qui était
développé sur place au terme d'une
vingtaine de minutes et après avoir
survolé le marion dufresne bernard se
pose à port aux français capital et
unique ville des kerguelen il retrouve
les bruits de la civilisation et la
banalité de l' architecture de la
commune française la plus sud du monde
si l'on excepte la base de terre adélie
en antarctique claquant fièrement au
vent des kerguelen de drapeaux bretons
nous rappelle que port aux français
aurait pu s'appeler port au breton tant
sont nombreux les bretons qui passèrent
par là
au terme d'une navigation prudente de
plus de six heures nos trois bretons
henry cédric et gildas arrive de port
jeanne d'arc
pour eux le voyage aucun galène s'achève
bien ici dans dix jours
ils seront de retour sur l'île de la
réunion
[Musique]
le matin de leur départ henry et bernard
se sont donné rendez vous au point
fondamental de tout les cartographies
moderne des kerguelen de caseros le cas
zéro à partir duquel tout a commencé
tous les travaux cartographique de
kerguelen en courant c'est à partir de
là c'est le point qui a été déterminé en
position ensuite faire une carte aussi
rigoureuse que précis sur un territoire
aussi difficile que les kerguelen relève
d'un tour de force et instaure entre les
équipes cartographique un respect mutuel
et fraternelle
aucune carte ne vient chasser l'autre
elle vient simplement l'enrichir en fait
il a été confirmé par des premiers
traits de crayon de kerguelen aux prises
de vues si sophistiqué du satellite spot
en passant par les frères rallier et
l'émission de l'hygiène faire la carte
des kerguelen fut vraiment toute une
histoire
l'écrivain argentin borghèse déclarait
la carte n'est pas le territoire
il avait doublement raison aucune carte
au monde ne parviendra à arracher aux
kerguelen le mystère de l'aube sombre
séduction
les cartographes auront beau partir et
même revenir les kerguelen conserveront
toujours par de vairelles leur
inexplicable lumière
[Musique]